communicating virtually is no longer a
convenience it's now a necessity as more
and more companies and classrooms
transition to online communication we
all can benefit from best practices to
ensure our ideas are communicated
clearly and concisely
my name is matt abrahams and i teach
strategic communication at stanford
graduate school of business
and welcome to a quick thinks episode of
think fast talk smart the podcast
[Music]
i believe there are four main areas to
explore as we strive to be more
effective and engaging online
communicators
so let's get started
the first has to do with what i call
virtual presenting hygiene this has to
do with how you've set up your
environment and tools
first and foremost it's important to
have a place that is quiet and has a
neutral background be thoughtful of the
lighting that you have
you can invest in professional lighting
for video or photography you want to
make sure that you have a camera that is
good quality you might want to purchase
an additional mic or a headset that has
a microphone in it when possible you
want your camera to be at your head
level when we communicate to people
we're used to looking them straight on
so you might need to raise your camera
you can do this by simply stacking a
bunch of books or you can actually buy a
professional stand you can always do a
recording to make sure that it looks and
sounds the way you like most of the
online tools that we use zoom webex
skype google hangouts they all have a
record feature once you have your
virtual hygiene established you want to
next focus on presence
presence has to do with how you appear
so we need to think about a couple
things first and foremost is you want to
look straight at the camera when you
present
many of us are enticed to look at our
notes or look at the little thumbnail
pictures of people on the screen and yet
to the people we're talking to it looks
like we're looking down so you want to
make sure you look directly at the
camera
i've been known to actually tape a
picture of family members or friends
right behind the camera so when i look
at the camera i see them and it feels a
little more natural it makes sense also
to try to stand when you present when we
stand we tend to be more focused we can
use more gestures we can breathe better
and we don't slouch so if possible set
up your environment so you can stand as
you present
and then finally a little extra tip get
yourself a slide advancer if you have a
slide advancer you can actually stand
farther away from your camera your
gestures can be seen and you can advance
slides very smoothly beyond presence we
have to think about engagement we have
all been part of webinars or web
meetings or even teleconferences that
are just disengaging so a couple ways to
invite your audiences to pay attention
rather than get distracted by all the
other things on their phones or on their
computers is to start by varying your
voice
humans are wired to pay attention to
novelty and things that change so if
you're monotone you're going to
disengage with your audience
a great way to do this is simply record
yourself and listen you don't have to
watch just listen and see if your voice
has variation if it doesn't you might
consider using more emotive words when
we use emotive words like excited or
challenged we tend to inflect those in
our voice next make sure you leverage
the tools of the virtual platform that
you're using many come with polling
features chat features some kind of
feedback where people can raise their
hand or signal you're going too slow or
too fast you can even send people
through a chat to an external document
like a google doc or a shared doc where
they do some work and you can see that
they're doing that work online that's a
way to get everybody engaged
finally invite people to show video
as you are presenting so if everybody
can see people we tend to pay attention
more
humans are wired to be intrigued by
others faces so if you see others faces
on the screen you're more likely to pay
attention
so we've talked about virtual hygiene
we've talked about your presence and
engagement let's talk about some things
you can do if you're actually leading
the webinar
or the virtual meeting first set
expectations and this comes in two
places
i think one of the most underutilized
features that we have to set
expectations is the meeting invite
in the meeting invite don't just specify
the url to go to and the time you can
actually set rules that you expect
people to follow for example state your
name before you present
or you can actually
include some questions that you want
people to think about when they come to
your meeting or your presentation that
way when you start you can start
immediately with engagement in those
questions so leverage the expectation
setting ability of the invites that you
send
second
when in the midst of your virtual
communication you want to solicit input
or start
dialogue with the people involved set
some boundaries set some expectations
and you need to do this more narrowly to
avoid people over speaking each other
when using technology there are some
built-in delays and we need to make sure
that we don't have people overstepping
each other and one way to do that is to
set boundaries or expectations that are
more narrow than you would if you were
in person so in person i might say i'd
now like to hear your thoughts on the
implementation plan i just discussed but
when you're virtual you might say now
i'd like to hear questions about the
cost of the implementation plan and
after those come in you may then say i'd
now like to talk about the
implementation timeline and as those
issues come in you can address them so
by taking narrower
sets of input or questions you actually
have fewer people over speaking so
managing those expectations are
important as well
finally when it comes to leading a
meeting we know from research that human
attention tends to dwindle after eight
to ten minutes so you want to make sure
that you quickly change things up maybe
you change speakers maybe you show a
short video clip maybe you take a poll
or go into dialogue q a mode but be sure
every eight to ten minutes that you're
changing things up to reinvigorate
people's attention so i hope you're
taking away from this quick thinks
episode of think fast talk smart
specific things you can do to be a
better online communicator it has to do
with your virtual hygiene your presence
your engagement and how you actually
lead when you're virtually communicating
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast
produced by stanford university's
graduate school of business for more
information and episodes visit
gsb.stanford.edu
or subscribe to our show wherever you
get your podcasts